[Music]
so we all know that an experience of
trauma can cause post-traumatic stress
disorder it can be an experience that
marks and fundamentally transforms the
character of a person it can make them
meet the world with fear so my question
is is the opposite also true can an
experience of such radiance of such
grace of such astonishment and beauty be
akin to a kind of inverse PTSD and can
be as fundamentally transformative to
the character structure of a person that
it now shifts their lenses of perception
to lenses that meet the world not with
fear but instead with curiosity we all
have these lenses of perception we see
with our lenses we see through the
lenses we don't see the lenses
themselves right this self construct
this lens of perception this ego is
something that we mistake for what we
are it's not a fixed unchanging thing in
fact it's an amalgamation of past
experiences right you become your
experiences your cells are a technology
that turns experience into biology so
essentially eventually you meet the
world through a prism of expectations
shaped by past trauma past experiences
until eventually that lens is clouding
your encounter with the world so much
it's akin to a kind of tunnel vision you
don't see the world as it is you see the
world as you are and what if that filter
on the world is not serving you what if
seeing the world as you are is a dark
lens what if you don't like who
you are can you change who you are
well it turns out that ego dissolving
experiences can make the possessor of a
lens of perception become aware that he
has a lens of perception and disposed of
lens of perception if it no longer
serves them we need encounters with the
numinous experiences that
recontextualize the self so that you
identify not with the small self but
with the self with a capital S you stop
tuning in to the broadcast of the ego
and you tune into the broadcast of the
whole and when you find another place to
plant your feet my friends when you meet
the world from a different vantage point
you see that you no longer are tethered
to that old monkey suit and that old
monkey mind and it is through these
moments of grace that you remember what
you forgot right you fundamentally
transform to your self system and
perhaps now can meet the world not with
fear but instead with curiosity you have
been absolved
[Music]
yeah you have been absolved hey now the
world becomes wealth a playground